monsieur le premier ministre sur les
retraites la droite a porté les trois
grandes réformes de ces trente dernières
années nous avons ainsi sauver notre
système par répartition auquel
d'ailleurs les français sont très
attachés
il le revendique à la fois comme un
héritage républicain et comme l'un des
piliers de notre modèle social
votre méthode de concertation monsieur
le premier ministre a été reconnaissant
un fiasco total
car non seulement votre projet de plus
en plus illisible mais il est de plus en
plus anxiogène
les français ne veulent pas d'un système
par points qui fera un nombre
considérable deux perdants et de
sacrifier et en premier lieu desquels
les femmes vos atermoiements et
disons-le homme monsieur le premier
ministre
vos mensonges sur le fond font courir un
risque inconsidéré
si du blocage économique de notre pays
une chose est certaine les régimes de
retraite de fait très fort mais je vous
le dis d'autant plus que notre famille
politique à assumer des réformes
courageuses dans ce domaine il ya eu la
réforme balladur
la réforme fillon la réforme woerth il
faut rendre à césar ce qui est à césar
si réforme ont sauvé de la faillite le
régime de retraite de nos compatriotes
si l'on a bien compris que le retour à
l'équilibré du système actuel sera la
sphère des partenaires sociaux avec
l'âge pivot à 64 ans d'ici 2027 et non
vous n'avez rien dit monsieur le premier
ministre du coup des mesures de
transition et des mesures nouvelles ni
de la manière dont vous allez les
financer lourdement pénalisé par le
mouvement des gilets jaunes l'année
dernière de nombreux commerçants
espéraient rétablir leur situation
financière
en ce mois de décembre or avec les
grèves c'est une nouvelle épreuve qui
s'abat sur eux toute l'économie
française est en effet durement touchée
selon la ces pme une journée de grève
coûte 400 millions d'euros au pays
pourquoi monsieur le président et vous
pas capables d'exiger un service minimum
qui garantirait la liberté de mouvement
à ceux qui veulent travailler
si le droit de grève est un principe
fondamental de notre démocratie ce que
nous respectons il est malheureusement
devenu le droit de bloquer trouvez-vous
tolérable que bus m
rer ter transilien soit à l'arrêt ou
presque des heures interminables de
galère la boule au ventre
matin et soir sous la pluie et dans le
froid pour aller gagner leur vie et le
droit de payer leurs impôts pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la chance d'habiter à
proximité de leur lieu de travail
c'est inadmissible le droit de grève
n'est pas le droit de bloquer le pays
monsieur le premier ministre quelle
considération porte votre gouvernement
aux familles nombreuses
alors que vous voulez maintenir un
système de retraite par répartition où
les actifs cotisent pour les retraités
vous semblez oublier que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui seront les actifs de
demain
ce n'est pas logique à force de saper la
politique familiale la natalité baisse
en france
[Musique]
m